when self-isolation first started I was
like you know what this is gonna be a
piece of cake I work from home I'm at
home all the time
this should be a cakewalk
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a lot harder than I thought it
would be especially at the beginning my
sleep schedule went to crap I stopped
showering right when I got up because I
didn't really have anywhere to be I also
started playing a lot more video games
looking for movement dude my favorite
thing in this game is running people
over with my car that's my favorite
thing in general so I think part of the
reason why this quarantine was so
challenging was because I think there's
a huge difference between spending time
at home and not being able to leave home
so for instance with my own work habits
yeah I work from home but I also have
this habit of leaving the house whenever
I'm starting to reach a wall and right
productivity or when I'm kind of goofing
off a little bit I'll say you know what
I should hit a coffee shop and start
writing but I don't have that option
anymore I also usually like hitting the
gym getting the blood pumping so that
you can take your mind off things
re energizing you for the day but
there's no gym anymore they're all
closed another huge barrier that I've
been encountering is that I share this
house with three other guys who I'm
quarantine with so since they're not
going to university or work anymore
they're just here all day long and we're
all really good friends so we distract
each other along Joe he's filming Johnny
pace yeah I'm filming you guys can play
FX I can't play bikes right now
thankfully though over the past week in
a bit I've really started to ramp up the
productivity I'm starting to feel more
optimistic like myself again I'm kind of
getting used to this whole quarantine
thing so I wanted to share with you guys
some of the things that have really
helped me climb out of this kind of
quarantine induced chaotic what am I
even saying I got out of a rut basically
okay so the first thing I want to touch
on is that you need to be aware of the
yo-yo effect so let me know if you've
ever been in this situation you're in a
little bit of a rut you're playing more
video games you're not really taking
care of yourself you're just generally
kind of slothful you've lost your
motivation to be productive and you kind
of divulge into this self-destruction
and pleasure-seeking mindset for a long
enough period of time until you reach a
breaking
point where you're like wow I really
feel like a piece of crap I'm gonna make
massive change I'm gonna take massive
action so you quickly do a little 3 6 9
360 because if you did a 360 we go in
the same way but you do a 180 and you
start going the other direction and you
start being super productive almost
unnaturally productive you're starting
to hit the gym you're moisturizing your
face even though you never did that
before
you're clipping your nails Shou why is
everything I talk about to do with
grooming you're getting your work done
on time
you're just insanely productive and
you're starting to feel really good but
you have a feeling in the back of your
mind that it's unsustainable and you
eventually push yourself so hard you get
burnt out you lose all of your energy so
you yo-yo back in the other direction
and the cycle repeats itself so if
you've ever succumbed to the yo-yo
effect I'd imagine if you're a human
being you have at some point in your
life there's a couple reasons why this
happens first of all you didn't do the
productive things long enough for them
to be locked in as a habit and the word
habits kind of lost its meaning but I
mean something that is easier to do than
it is not to do once something is a
habit you don't really have to worry
about yo-yoing back as much because it's
kind of locked in psychologically the
second reason why we yo-yo is because
the habits that we try to adopt into our
new lifestyle are so extreme we bite off
more than we can chew basically so it's
really important to pick one or two easy
things that are simple to do that you
can actually count on yourself to
achieve daily lock these things in as
simple daily habits until they're easier
to do than not to do that way you won't
get burnt out by doing them ok so what
does this have to do with the quarantine
well that's my next point the morning is
the key one thing I've noticed
especially during this quarantine is
that your morning shapes the entire rest
of your day in a pre-pandemic Society
people usually wake up they shower they
get dressed pop something in their mouth
maybe grab a coffee because they have
somewhere to be they get out the door to
go to work or school and that's the
reason for kind of taking their morning
seriously or you
into battle mode but during the
quarantine it's sort of hard to flip
that switch into battle mode because
you're kind of just staying at home and
even if you are working from home most
people don't see the necessity to treat
working from home the same as they would
leaving to go to work but it is
extremely important to do so whenever
you shower and get dressed you kind of
flip a switch in your brain that says
I'm in work mode now or school mode now
or at least I'm ready to start the day
and if you wait to shower and you wait
till later in the day to get dressed or
you never get dressed
you're either postponing flipping the
switch or not flipping the switch in
general for me flipping the switch comes
down to a very simple decision that I
have to make when I first wake up I can
either choose the door on the left which
leads to outside my room and going
through that door always leads to me
going down the stairs making coffee and
browsing memes for half an hour or the
first hour of the day checking social
media etc or I can choose the second
door which is the door on my right which
leads into my bathroom which always
leads to me taking a shower putting
clothes on and then walking downstairs
it's a very simple decision but mentally
I'm like two completely different people
when I shower versus when I don't shower
when I'm in sweatpants versus when I
actually got ready for the day
sweatpants me likes to browse memes and
check social media and Benji you too
showered me he likes to light a candle
and write some content for YouTube so
find out what your little decision is
that you have to make every single
morning and flip that switch as early as
possible the third point I want to make
is to leverage boredom so the quarantine
is really boring spending all day every
single day inside is kind of a bummer
you start to run out of stuff to do
pretty quickly but something I never
talked about with you guys on this
channel is that this channel only exists
because of boredom and I only continued
to make videos early on especially when
I wasn't getting any views because of
boredom
ask my mom like hey can I invite my
friends over and once we played halo
co-op on legendary too much we got bored
of that we went made a movie they I
don't think I'd be making videos today
if I wasn't bored back then with my
friends I was still in university and
between classes and studying I didn't
have an xbox or a PC capable of running
very many games in fact I used a
Chromebook for the majority of my
university career and I was itching to
find something to do with my time
something to work on or work towards and
that's why I started this channel when
we fill every single parcel of time with
something to do with a screen to look at
or a show to watch we almost lose touch
with ourselves but this aloneness or
this boredom is extremely important
because it helps you uncover things that
you need to address it can either lead
you to think about and accept something
traumatizing that happen to you in the
past or sometimes it's not that scary
and you just have this underlying
anxiety because you haven't paid your
taxes yet all these emails and letters
are starting to pile up and this anxiety
is the catalyst for taking action on
those things but if you keep distracting
yourself you're never gonna have that
you're never going to be scared into
taking action you know that boredom
created sort of like this itch to you
know go do something to be
you know to fill time instead of just
like having your time filled for you via
social media so you're gonna have a lot
of time during this quarantine to sit
alone with your thoughts and try to
figure out what the most important thing
in your life is don't distract yourself
from this feeling so the last point I
want to talk about is probably the most
important and that's this idea of using
the quarantine to your advantage it's
very easy to take on a victim role in
fact it makes a lot of sense there's a
compelling reason to play the victim
during a pandemic because you can't
really do anything about it it feels out
of your control it's scary it's
unshredded territory
there's tons of reasons why you can fall
into feeling helpless or confused or or
lose your way in some form or another
it's a lot harder but probably a lot
more advantageous to view it as an
opportunity because the nature of being
on house arrest for 24/7 actually has a
huge advantage and that's because you
have a tremendous amount of
predictability with what your day looks
like and that is the breeding ground for
developing healthy habits if every day
feels like Groundhog Day
then that's the perfect opportunity this
is fertile soil for developing habits a
lot of people can't start healthy habits
during their regular life because you
know things pop up you know maybe you
have to go away for work little Johnny
has a baseball game you have to go watch
so you have to skip the gym there's all
these little things that regular life
throws at you
Quarantine life is a lot more boring a
lot more monotonous but a lot more
predictable so this is probably the best
opportunity of your life to lock in
habits that you can then take into your
normal life once this whole thing blows
over and if you're someone who has
generally struggled to implement good
habits if you're somebody who's tried to
meditate for a day or two or three and
then it kind of falls off or you try to
develop a habit of reading and then that
kind of falls off then I'm actually
going to rear ekam end a book that I've
are
recommended on this channel but I think
it's the most important book you can
read at a time like this and that is
atomic habits by James clear I'm
rereading it myself and I'm uncovering
so many things that I somehow missed
before and it's making me realize it's
one of those books that you should read
several times and I highly recommend
checking out the audiobook version
specifically using today's video sponsor
audible and that is because it's
actually narrated by the author himself
so his personal anecdotes that he wrote
about in the book really hit home and
feel more personal not only does audible
have the largest selection of audiobooks
on the entire internet but every single
month they send you one credit which you
can spend on any audiobook in their
entire library and they also send you to
audible originals and one of the best
things about audible is that if you
decide to cancel your subscription at
any point you still keep your entire
library of books including the books
that you got for free using their credit
system so it's kind of a no-brainer
especially at a time like this when you
have the opportunity to develop a
reading habit so to sign up for your
free 30-day trial and listen to James
clears atomic habits click the link in
the description below or text better
ideas to 500 500 once again to sign up
for your free 30-day trial click the
link in the description or text better
ideas to 500 500
so I was editing this video and I
figured that I would take this
opportunity to tell you about Mormonism
now so we're almost at 10,000 followers
on Instagram the other day you guys
helped me cook dinner over a live stream
and that was kind of hilarious and it
turned out pretty well actually and also
the minute that we hit 10,000 followers
I'm gonna be giving away a bunch of
Kindles so the way you enter that is
just by following me on Instagram so
make sure to click the link in the
description below give it a follow and
it'll be a fun time if you like this
video make sure to hit like because when
you hit like the algorithm does fancy
things and my face ends up on peep
homepages and maybe during the
quarantine this video can help people
get their act together so it's kind of a
win-win for everybody if you're lurking
here consider subscribing and hitting
the bell icon so that you don't miss
future videos a lot of people are asking
about the inaction is the slow death
merge and where they can get it
I think the teespring shelf still shows
up on mobile but in any case we're
redesigning the shirts we're making some
sweatshirts and all that kind of stuff I
need to wait for it to come in the mail
so I can take some product shots etc etc
but yeah they look awesome but other
than that thanks a lot for watching and
we'll catch you in the next video stay
safe out there wash your hands I think
everyone's saying that I'm not special